[Musique]
bonsoir nouvelle édition du 78 sur TVfil
78 merci de nous rejoindre en direct à
18h en ce 14 mars ce soir je recevrai la
coprésidente et la trésorière du MP de
550 an en Yveline le mouvement contre le
racisme et pour l'amitié entre les
peuples qui s'engagent en faveur du
droit de vote des étrangers aux
élections locales alors que François
Hollande semble avoir renoncé à cet
engagement de campagne également en
plateau tout à l'heure l'un des
responsabl de laasmb rugby pour les
rencontres espoir du Stade Français qui
se joueront le dimanche à Montini le
Bretonneux et j'accueille déjà sur ce
plateau Philippe guirud bonsoir à vous
vous êtes l'un des organisateurs du
tournoi international d'aéromodélisme
qui débute demain vendredi au clés
sous-bois c'est devenu un rendez-vous
incontournable vous avez réussi à
imposer ce rendez-vous aujourd'hi tout à
fait c'est une compétition qui est
unique en Europe voire au monde et on va
détailler tout ça tout à l'heure avec
vous vous allez nous dire un petit peu
quels sont les les différents
compétiteurs qui vont venir s'affronter
durant plusieurs jours au clés sous-bois
et puis nous parlerons économie
également ce soir la chronique de l'écho
avec Claire Cambier bonsoir claire
bonsoir Le Salon du livre de Paris
débute le 22 mars c'est donc l'occasion
de parler du marché du livre alors
quelles évolutions ces dernières années
comment se pent le secteurs comment
traverse-t-il la crise le directeur de
la maison d'édition inoctavo sera ce sur
ce plateau pour nous en parler
rendez-vous dans une vingtaine de
minutes pour cette chronique de l'cho
les titres à présent les reportages
également à découvrir ce soir nous nous
sommes rendus auprès de la communauté
catholique de 50 ans en iveline pour
recueillir leur réaction au lendemain de
l'élection d'un nouveau pape Monseigneur
omonier évec de Versailles s'est déclaré
très heureux de cette élection une des
conséquences inattendues des intempéries
la chute du nombre de dons du sang des
collectes mobiles ont été annulées en
raison des chutes de neige les besoins
au quotidien en Île-de-France ne sont
pas assurés et pourtant c'est un acte
indispensable le Salon du livre de Paris
ouvre du 22 au 25 mars l'occasion de
nous intéresser à de nouveaux concepts
de librairie c'est le cas de cette
boutique que vous apercevez de Fontenis
le Fleury où l'on peut acheter un livre
mais aussi échanger lors de cercle de
lecture et pourquoi pas trouver des
jouets mais aussi des bijoux les
médiatèquees de cquanttins en Yveline
s'automatise les livres sont équipés de
puces les abonnés peuvent tout seul
emprunter et venir rendre leurs ouvrages
Manamo est la première médiathèque à
être équipée de ce système voilà pour
les titres de ce soir on passe à présent
à notre fait du jour cette élection hier
soir à 19h du nouveau
[Musique]
pape le 266e pape est donc connu le
cardinal d'Amérique latine Bergoglio est
devenu hier soir le pape François le
monde entier fait sa connaissance et il
fait la connaissance avec celui qui
succède à Benoît 16 les mots rupture
simplicité reviennent le plus souvent
qu'en pensent les catholiques
desivvelines reportage à gui en cours de
Julie Rocha soirz et d'éodie moine Abé
mous Papam nous avons un pape les
catholiques vont désormais célébrer
chaque jour François à l'église
Saint-Victor de guyancour les fidèles
étaient déjà émus avant la messe ce
jeudi midi je viens pour remercier
justement à Dieu pour l'élection de Pape
François 1ier je suis très heureuse pour
l'élection du nouveau pape parce que ça
donne une joie à l'église d'avoir un
pape d'un are continent mais qui est
pour tout le monde quelque chose de
nouveau vous êtes content oui madame un
moment fort partagé avec le jeune père
Fabrice duet qui vit son premier
changement de souverain pontif c'est une
nouvelle figure pour laquel on va prier
au
quotidien qui va pouvoir aussi donner
certaines directions à l'église et
chaque pape et ben euh arrive avec ses
idées avec des projets pour l'Église
donc ça va changer un certain nombre de
choses même s'il faut pas s'attendre à
une révolution majeure dans les quelques
semaines ce nouveau pape le pape
François et ben euh imprimera euh
l'histoire de l'Église à sa manière un
pape Jésu donc les Jésuites vous savez
ce sont des prêtres religieux qui ont
fait le vœu de pauvreté et qui vivent de
manière assez exigeante cette pauvreté
François euh bah ça fait référence à
Saint-François d'Assise saint-fançois
d'assise et le saint par excellence qui
incarne la vertu de la pauvreté qui
incarne aussi l'amour de la nature
l'amour le dialogue interreligieux
François Saint-François avait été
discuté avec les musulmans à l'époque où
ce dialogue était plus que complexe donc
ça dit déjà fortement quelque chose de
la manière dont il sera pape en chaque
messe le pape est nommé on nomme le pape
et l'évêque par leur prénom alors tout
l'enjeu c'est de pas se tromper de pas
mettre notre Pape Benoît à à ce
moment-là le pape François que tu as
établi à sa tête par Jésus le Christ
notre Seigneur sa première fois c'est
bien passé et restera un souvenir
extraordinaire tout comme la découverte
du pape hier soir au moment où j'ai
appris que la fumée était blanche je
recevait un couple en préparation au
mariage j'étais dans mon bureau au
presbytère donc je leur ai dit est-ce
que je crois qu'ils ont un peu halluciné
mais je leur ai dit est-ce qu'on peut
tout arrêter parce qu'il faut qu'on voit
le nouveau PAP puis je suis allé
chercher une bouteille de champagne et
donc avec ce couple on a débouché la
bouteille de champagne et accueilli le
nouveau pape et une fois seulement qu'on
savait qui c'était j'ai fermé mon
ordinateur et on a pu continuer la
préparation au
mariage c'est une façon de célébrer
aussi l'arrivée de ce nouveau pape que
pensez-vous du de ce choix de l'Église
catholique nous sommes allés vous poser
la question aujourd'hui et puis sachez
que nous reviendrons aussi dans notre
édition de lundi sur cette élection les
réactions dans le département avec
notamment Christine Boutin la présidente
du Parti Chrétien déémocrate également
conseillère général des yvelin sur le
canton de Rambouillet en attendant voici
vos réactions ah moi je trouve qu'il est
très bien parce que il a l'air très près
du peuple surtout ce qui est très
intéressant parce que un pape un peu
autoritaire c'est pas très bon non plus
j'ai à peine vu je crois que c'est
François 1er mais j' pense pas
grandchose je sais même pas qui c'est ni
jamais entendu parler de lui donc
simplement je suis très satisfaite que
ce soit un PAP non européen et que que
ce soit un pape qui apparemment enfin ce
qui ce qui en est dit c'est qui qui
s'occupe plus des pauvre que de la haute
société donc ma fois c'est pas plus mal
ça peut changer peut-être les choses
enfin il reste très traditionnaliste
ceci dit on verra moi ça m'est
complètement égal en fait après il y a
du travail et voilà qu'il le fasse c'est
bien c'est merveilleux c'est différent
ça change quelqu'un qui vient d'un autre
continent il a l' gentil souriant on
verra bien ce qui se passe